heute ist daniel cohn bendit zum zweiten
mal gast moderator der sternstunde
philosophie in den vergangenen tagen
wurde con wendet mit pädophilie
vorwürfen konfrontiert wir nehmen diese
debatte zur kenntnis die vorwürfe aber
sind nicht neu daniel cohn bendit hat
dazu immer wieder stellung genommen und
betont dass er nicht pädophil ist dass
er keine übergriffe auf kinder begangen
hat und es diesbezüglich auch nie zu
einer anzeige gekommen ist
heute diskutiert daniel cohn bendit mit
peter von matt darüber was die schweiz
im innersten zusammen hält der germanist
peter von matt ist nämlich seine art
tiefenpsychologie der schweizer
willensnation und europäer daniel cohn
bendit will wissen wie die schweiz
schickt nämlich so ein bisschen anders
als andere in europa hunderte von man
also sie haben 2012 ein essay band
veröffentlichen haben den schweizer
buchpreis auch erhalten dafür und er ein
ist er am sie neu geschrieben ich lese
den titel vor die schweiz zwischen
ursprung und fortschritt zur seelen
geschichte einer nation
sie fangen an in diesem essay mit einer
interpretation dieses bildes erstmal
also warum dieses bild die gott ab post
ja warum von und zweitens sie
interpretieren dass im grunde genommen
mehrere mal sagen sie uns warum fangen
sie es mit so einem bild an dieses bild
ist eines der bekanntesten und
berühmtesten bilder der schweiz
ausserhalb der schweiz kennt das niemand
aber in der schweiz wissen alle leute wo
das mal gehangen hat bei den großeltern
oder 1873 ja 70er jahren des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts und alle haben da eine
erinnerung daran ich habe sehr viele
etwas bekommen und alle haben gesagt das
bild war darum aus dortmund das war
damals dort das war sehr populär
es ist ein bild das eigentlich populär
ist weil es die gute alte zeit
verkörpert die postkutschen zeit und so
weiter aber tatsächlich und das habe ich
dann bei der arbeit an diesem bild
gesehen ist es ein sehr doppeldeutige
bild es ist ja auch eine gefährliche
situation
es ist ein kalb da das vor den pferden
vor den rennenden pferden davon läuft
dann weiß nicht wird es überfahren kommt
es um stürze kutcher hat angst hat
offensichtlich angst es also eigentlich
auch eine gefährliche situation ist die
straße die alle leute kennen auf der
südseite des st gotthard eine immer noch
gefährliche straße und das hat mich
fasziniert ich bin dann demnach gegangen
ich habe die geschichte des bildes
untersucht das ist das war schon
erforscht aber das musste man dann
zusammentragen und das spannende war
dass es eigentlich
gleichzeitig war zur gleichen zeit als
das entstand war ein echter eisenbahn
tunnel schon fast fertig also ein
bisschen unterhalb dieses dieser stelle
wird aus bild spielt wenn man so sagen
kann war der raiffeisenbank und fertig
und damit war es mit dem postkutschen
dann vorbei ja aber da gibt es auch
diese kühe die sind überhaupt nicht
verängstigt wenn man diese die sind eher
gelangweilt schauen sich dem schauspiel
chance in dem schauspiel zu und sie
sahen es ist nicht nur ein konservatives
manifest sondern sie erklären uns das
eigentlich dieses bild auch das problem
von ursprung und moderne darstellt und
die gefahr dass ist ja dass die
neuinterpretation oder die
interpretation sie bringe weil das bild
von verschiedenen geschwindigkeiten
spricht und der prozess der
modernisierung ist immer auch
in konflikte geschwindigkeiten konflikt
zwischen den bestehenden das langsam
oder stehend ist und zwischen dem neuen
das als schnell überstürzen erlebt wird
und hier haben wir das der maler hat so
etwas hier gemalt
obwohl man es eigentlich dann als das
gegenteil nämlich als ein zeugnis des
einstigen tausenden gelesen hat aber
wenn man es genau betrachtet dann sieht
man dass es hier wirklich bereits um den
konflikt unterschiedliche
geschwindigkeiten geht und die sind auch
in der zeitgenössischen theorie bei jako
burka zum beispiel wird darauf großes
gewicht gelegt dass die veränderung der
geschwindigkeit in der zivilisation sagt
burkhard ist gleichzeitig ein
fundamentales krisensymptom gut
versuchen wir mal jetzt zur schweiz
gekommen um diese diese entwicklung
dieses problem zwischen das alte und das
neue mal ran zu kommen wie sie es machen
in ihrem aufsatz sie empfangen dann mit
alfred von haller mit seinem text die
alpen und sagen das ist sowieso ein
gründungsmythos den mythos der
eigentlichen schweiz und für sie
das ist der ausgangspunkt ihrer
überlegung über die die seelen den
seelenzustand der zum schweiz oder die
widersprüche alfred von haller 1730 wenn
ich mich nicht die alfa laval berechnung
zu lina recht gut
die schweiz hat sich ja eigentlich immer
von den bergen her definiert obwohl die
geschichte der schweiz die wirklichkeit
der schweiz ist eine urbane geschichte
eine geschichte der städte die
entwicklung die der fortschritt das neue
ist immer innenstädten geschehen und ist
immer noch so aber zum zur
selbstverständigung der schweiz
gehörte das bewusstsein wir haben die
berge und die berge sind ewig gewerbe
sind unveränderlich auf dem berger ist
der ewige schnee da verändert sich nicht
die ewigen gletscher dieses gefühl der
schweiz etwas zu besitzen das absolut
unveränderlich ewig und vollkommenes das
gehörte sehr wesentlich zum
selbstbewusstsein und das ist natürlich
inzwischen kollabiert
sie zitieren ja halla der sarg versucht
ihr sterblichen macht euer zustand
besser als dieser er es eigentlich sagt
probier's mal aber im grunde sagt es
wird nicht klappen wenn er sagt die
hintergrund meinung ist versuchte
sterblichen machten zustand besser ihr
werdet nichts finden keinen ort auf der
erde finden in dem der zustand der
menschen besser ist als jetzt in den
schweizer bergen ist das war dass die
große these von haller und er hat gesagt
ich bin wissenschaftler war wissenschaft
allen der berühmtesten
naturwissenschaftler des 18 jahrhunderts
und erkrath ich hab's gesehen
ich bin dort gewesen ich bin augenzeuge
dort existiert noch das goldene
zeitalter explizite aber sie sagen
dieser dieser naturwissenschaftler
verfälscht die realität
das ist eigentlich eine illusion mythos
des goldene zeitalter ist ein fantasie
bis jahresanfang dass er den mädchen
ging es gar nicht so gut
nein ich meine die bevölkerung in den
outen war arm die jungen männer mussten
auswandern mussten in die kriegs dienste
kamen verkrüppelt zurück die
kindersterblichkeit war hoch der
dinara mangelhaft also das kinn denen
nicht gut aber halle hat das antike
modell von arkadien aus ästhetisches
modell übernommen hat es in die mitte
frei gesetzt hat gesagt so wie die
visionen der vollkommenen gesellschaft
bei den alten römern und griechen
ausgesehen haben so ist es heute noch
mitten in den alpen das war seine sein
programm und das hat europäisch
durchgeschlagen alle haben das genau sie
sagen sogar dass russo im grunde
genommen bei haller irgendwie rekurriert
erlöse aber aber von haller nehmen sie
so diese triade natur vernunft freiheit
das wäre im grunde genommen die mythos
triade der schweiz
ich kann jetzt nicht sagen das ist die
möglichst reale der realen schweiz
aber das war die offerte die haller
gemacht hat und er hat diese begriffe
noch bevor sie zu politisch brisanten
begriffen wurden in paris oder in
amerika hat er sie eigentlich ins
zentrum gerückt und das ist das
merkwürdige weil er
man würde ja erhalten im frühen
achtzehnten jahrhundert würde das noch
christlich überfahren
das ist gleichzeitig ein gläubiges fall
kommt wie es im 19 jahrhundert sich
jemand scorpions volk verstanden
davon ist bei hana keine rede es ist
eigentlich packen also 1000 volks kommt
kein priester vorhang eine kirche in
diesem bild das zeigt alles wie nötig
das ist auch wie konstruiert und wie
dann welchen effekt das gemacht aber das
interessante ist dass sie in dieser
diskussion normaler plötzlich kommt auch
sehr einfliegen lassen
der französische humanes der auch im
grunde genommen ja geschrieben hat das
alte wird verschwinden die vernunft
versiegen
sie sind sie sagen ja der ist ja auch
die routiniert worden ja also lange hat
die vernunft nicht durch keinen bestand
gablinger französischen revolution
warum diese gegenüberstellung von kunduz
see und und halle in dieser entwicklung
weil konnte in diesem text geradezu
vorbildlich und lapidar
denn einen neuen geschichts begriff
lanciert die geschichte als ein gerade
ausgerichtete prozess des fortschritts
zu immer besseren bis hin zur
vollkommenen gesellschaft also was den
hebel übernommen atommarkt alles die
haben ja immer den marian kommenden
gehört ja das ziel ist die vollkommene
gesellschaft und die menschheit ist auf
dem weg also diese diese neue glaubens
akt der die das christliche weltbild
abgelöst hat dass die menschheit selber
auf dem weg zu dem von ihr selber
verfertigten paradies ist das wird von
bose skizziert und halle ist insofern
interessant als eigentlich von diesem
gedanken der selbst verbesserung
gestreiftes versucht hier sterbliche
macht euren zustand besser aber dank den
schluss zieht dass arbeiter geht in die
schweiz am seht ihr dass es eigentlich
die vollkommene gesellschaft dort schon
vorhanden ist und die schweiz hat das
dann sehr gern geglaubt und ganz europa
hat es geglaubt und und ihre ihr einwurf
mit condor said dass er im grunde warum
diese diese positive
geschichtsphilosophie der wurde er zum
opfer gleich indem er wie gesagt
routiniert wurde also nicht lange konnte
seinen optimismus mit ihm leben ja gut
aber die guillotine hat ihn ja nicht
widerlegt also die idee ist dadurch ja
nicht vernichtet worden also die idee
hatte er dann das ganze 1920 sehr
wundert da ist verankert etwas wir
kommen darauf über den menschen und die
widersprüche der menschen in die
geschichte machen
wir gehen weiter sie
denn dann weiter wir sie gehen in ihrem
essay wetter und kommen bei gottfried
keller der im grunde norm sang sie
gottfried keller formuliert einem riss
in diesem bild der schönen schweiz der
ist der autor der im grunde genommen die
schweiz vielleicht realer sieht als zum
beispiel haller ja das ist das stimmt
ganz sicher dass er ihr realer sieht
aber er ist natürlich eine angehörige
einer späteren generation er ist die
generation die dann 18 48 die neue
schweiz mit der neuen verfassung gemacht
hat die die amerikanische verfassung
kopiert und auf die schweiz übertragen
hat er ist ursprünglich der vertreter
des liberalen fortschrittlich liberalen
aufbruchs der war sehr rasch eben die
auch die probleme die widersprüche
dieses neuen staates gesehen hatte
abgesehen dass es dass die dynamik der
politik allein nicht den staat bestimmt
sondern dass wir die politik haben und
daneben die dynamik der wirtschaft
die dynamik der ausbeutung der natur und
das da risse entstehen im gesamtbild und
das dann wieder für ihn stehen die
müssen aus gehalten werden da machen sie
so ein kleiner exkurs erstmal was ich
spannend fand es was ist konservativ und
was ist modern und irgendwie dieser
richtig ist was kommen wird aber kommen
wird war einmal was einmal war ist dann
der konservativ progressive und der
progressive konservativen sie drehen das
um und sah so einfach ist mit
die konservativen sind für das alte und
die modernen sinn für was neues sondern
im grunde genommen vermischt ich das
oder widerspricht sich das auch manchmal
etwas beide der die sogenannten
fortschritts parteien wie die
sogenannten bewahrung parteien berufen
sich ja immer auf ein modell in der
vergangenheit
die französische revolution hat sich auf
die römische republik berufen
man geht immer zurück und sagt dort dann
aus weit hinten
da gab es das maß das was für uns immer
noch der maßstab ist und daran müssen
wir uns messen
und deshalb ist dieses vorwärts heißt
immer auch zurück zu
und da rauskommt die paradoxie jeder
konservativen und jeder
fortschrittlichen politischen position
ja aber dann sagen dann sagen sie ja
wenn ein land ein land dessen politische
fantasie aus jenen alb märchen erbt muss
es unverzüglich unverzeihlich zu
konflikten zwischen ursprungs vision und
dem technischen fortschritt kommen ja
das ist für sie jetzt im grunde genommen
das problem der schweiz
man könnte sagen nicht nur der schweiz
sicher das problem dass europas ist das
problem jeder jedes landes das mit der
modernen technik und zivilisation und
wirtschaft verbunden ist und die das
merkwürdige ist das sind da da gibt es
eben andere ökologische fakten dahinter
dass wir nur wissen wer wir sind wenn
wir wissen wer wir waren also angesagt
zukunft braucht herkommen aber herkunft
war zur herkunft zukunft braucht
herkunft
man kann natürlich auch umgekehrt
herkunft schafft zukunft aber dieses
dieses paradoxe verhältnis zu etwas
woran man sich hält und was gültig ist
das dann ermöglicht dass das dann die
veränderung ermöglicht das sind diese
widersprüche diese verwicklungen die
dann in der täglichen politik gar nicht
wirklich durch diskutiert werden aber
dass das sind die die fallen in die wir
immer wieder dran aber dann ist es
interessant denn dann machen sie
überraschen sie uns mich denn sie machen
aus gottfried keller dem uhr erzähler
der nachhaltigkeit wenn ihr wissen wird
woher das kommt dann lest gottfried
keller
und mit seiner tausendjährigen eiche ja
dass die dann der erste die erste
erwähnung des wortes nachhaltigkeit im
deutschen wörterbuch der brüder gering
ist ein zitat von jeremias gotthelf von
einem schweizer schriftstellers 19
jahrhundert es gibt in der schweiz
tatsächlich eine das wort nachhaltigkeit
habe damals nicht diese spezifische
bedeutung wie jetzt aber ist im
ungefähren schon und es gibt
insbesondere in den outen
diese vorstellung man darf man muss
aufpassen was man in der natur zerstört
und das hängt primär einmal zusammen mit
den mit den lawinen wo die wälder sind
die wälder welche die ortschaften vor
den lawinen schützen und diese wälder
wie die darf man nicht verletzen
die darf man nicht ausbeuten sonst kommt
die kartoffel das bewusstsein dass der
eingriff in die natur tödlich sein kann
für ganze talschaften ortschaften
das ist einfach aus der aus der
situation der schweiz entstanden wurde
aber auch wie bei gottfried keller der
nicht in den bergen gelebt hat der kann
bergsteiger waren der eigentlich nie von
den bergen sprechen aber er spricht von
den immer von den wäldern und spricht
den wäldern der gegend des kantons
zürich und beschreibt dort wie er findet
eine stadt im finale eine geschichte ja
und beschreibt wie die vernichtung von
wäldern
daneben auch sofort zu konsequenzen
führt einbruch von stürmen und
überschwemmungen und so weiter also
dieser zusammenhang von eingriff in die
natur und selbstzerstörung der
gesellschaft das wird dort
sehr deutlich gesagt aber er hat im
ansatz in der geschichte die sie
erzählen ja fast eine politische
erzählung über eben die den wert dieser
wälder den wähler sehr reichen
zerstörung der aisch und damit der
ökonomische zusammenbruch orte damit
zusammenhängen in seiner erfinder der
stadt das eltviller und er das ist eine
programmatisch symbolische szene nicht
die zerstörung einer wunderbaren uralten
eiche die angeblich noch in der
römerzeit zurück geht also eher
unwahrscheinlich ist
aber er zeigt damit dass es die zum
selbstbewusstsein eines staates und
verkehr keller lebte nach seinem
bewusstsein herren ganz jungen staat
nicht schweiz war neu und neu geschaffen
neu geordnet und das zum
selbstbewusstsein eines solchen staates
der schutz der natur gehört und der
schutz der natur diene und der nötigen
und nützliche einrichtung der
bestehenden einrichtung der natur also
diese kuriose erfindung der stadt
eltville
das sind ja alles faule 100 dieser
gegend man sagt immer dass sie den
begriff der schweizer spießbürger das
stimmt nicht ich weiß spießbürger sind
die arbeiten von morgen bis 8 sie gibt
arbeiten sind proteste vor
kapitalistisches dieses eltviller sie
machen alle konkurs wenn sie 40 erich
sind aber sie können weiter leben weil
diese stadt sehr große wälder hat
und die können sie nutzen und vermarkten
und sie nehmen nie mehr weg und sie
nehmen nie mehr holz aus den wäldern als
wieder nachwächst
das ist das nachhaltigkeitsprinzip da
bringt er eine nachhaltigkeits farbe
eigentlich herein sie sich entwickeln
dann und fangen an zu diskutieren die
schweiz ist die schweiz ein sonderfall
und sagen sonderfall ist erst mal
vielleicht der falsche begriff aber
jedes land hat einen nationalen stil
denn das sozialpolitische leben eines
land prägt was wie was ist für sie der
nationale stil der schweiz an diesem
jetzt wo wir nach mit gottfried keller
das könnte ich jetzt so eigentlich nicht
formulieren machen
es hat mir gefallen weil ich da kommt
man nicht stimmte man dann versteht man
es gibt unterschied obwohl sie alle im
gleichen saal ökonomischen system jahr
es ist sicher nicht so dass die schweiz
im gegensatz zu allen anderen
europäischen ländern etwas ganz und gar
spezielles wäre jedes land ist so
unterschiedlich empfinden sie die
europäischen länder gegeneinander halten
und überlegen dann sehen sie die haben
alle in einer weise ein eigenes gesicht
dass jedes land eigentlich ein
sonderfall ist aber in der schweiz gibt
es natürlich bestimmte gegebenheiten die
auffällig sind also die schweiz hat ja
die neue schweizer wussten ja nicht wie
sie die schweiz einrichten wollten 18 48
gab es einen bürgerkrieg vorher 47
bürgerkrieg zwischen konservativen und
den bürgerlichen liberalen ständen die
liberalen haben besiegten wollten einen
neuen zentralstaat einrichten und
wussten nicht wie man das macht und dann
kam einer der damaligen
intellektuellen und er hat gesagt ja das
einfachste wäre übernehmen die
verfassung der usa neutraler staat der
usa also mit diesen staaten wieder
delphi und haben aber dann und das kommt
dann kommt vielleicht der schweizerische
herein indem sie sucht haben aber dann
gesagt aber einen präsident das geht
nicht
die berner akzeptieren keinen server und
die innerschweizer keinen protestanten
aus präsidenten und die bündner sowieso
keiner aus dem thurgau aus dem tessin
und die kommen noch die roma aus dazu
die französische sprache genannt die
tessiner das geht nicht ein präsident
dann geht die schweiz am nächsten tag
kaputt dann machen wir 7
die haben also die funktion des
präsidenten präsidenten auf 7 aufgeteilt
und da konnten sie dann die
verschiedenen ecken und länder der
schweiz zusammen bringen das ist das was
wir heute das prinzip der konkordanz
nennen also dass wir haben eigentlich
eine eingerichtete alle parteien
regierung oder mehr parteien regierung
es ging dann lange auf der am anfang war
nur direkt waren nur die die liberalen
im bundesrat das war jahrelang
eigentlich eine ein parteien regierung
kamen mit der zeit die katholisch
konservativen viel später dann noch die
sozialdemokraten und eigentlich 100
jahre nach der gründung des neuen
staates würde dann der bundesrat
sozusagen zu diesem mit auch aus den
verschiedenen parteien und dann haben
sie eine für mich wieder überraschende
formulierung sie sagen die schweiz ist
kein sonderfall
sie hat nur eine sonder fantasie
also fantasie von sich selbst das ist
das besondere
also wenn sie wollen dass die verlegung
des nation der nationale stil ist so
habe ich verstanden
er plädiert ist die sonder von der sie
identität ist ein fantasieprodukt man
kann die identität gibt es nur über die
herkunft das wissen vor mit der herkunft
und das wissen wo man hin will und dazu
braucht es fantasiebilder die
vergangenheit wird immer konstruiert
jedes land konstruiert seine
vergangenheit und dann sagt es wir sind
die die das damals waren und das war
natürlich ein dass es kein sonderfall
das war ein bewusst provokativ
ersatzwahl das ist ein heiliges
neutralität sagt jetzt vergessen sie die
es uns aufgezogen worden
natürlich das sind einfach die jedes
land hat natürlich auch seine heiligen
setzte und die verwender schweiz ist so
ein heiliger satz den ich nie ganz
verstanden habe dass sie anders ist als
andere länder
ist ja klar aber alle länder sind anders
als die anderen länder und bestimmte
dinge eigenheiten hat sie sich und es
geht eben darum wenn es die schweiz ist
schon ein land in dem es eure heiligen
seite immer noch gibt und wenn man da
gelegentlich einen steinernen hühnerhof
wirft gibt es eingeflochten
das ist doch wohl touren er weil sie
sagen ja dieser isolationismus der ist
ja von den mächten in der indie in den
zehn derzeit sagt im grunde genommen
aufgedrückt worden
dann ja okay ihr könnt aber ihr müsst
zulassen dass die wege offen sind und
ansonsten müsst ihr neutral bleiben ja
es war nicht die schweiz sagen wir
wollen neutralen seinerseits wurde ihm
gesagt ihr müsst ja das ist mir
natürlich beides die schweizer wollten
auch irgendwann nicht mehr auf jedem
schlachtfeld mit streitenden rote
umständen die leute vom nachbardorf
totschlagen
aber die neutralität der schweiz aus ein
politisches eine politische strategie
ist ebenso sehr wahrscheinlich muss man
so seit eben so sehr das produkt der
politik der europäischen nationalstaaten
wie es das produkt des staats willens
der schweiz ist denn es ging um die
pässe
das ging das ganze 19 jahrhundert dann
auch noch im zwanzigsten jahrhundert um
die pässe und da war die idee der
großmächte natürlich sehr rasch wenn wir
die schweizer haben die dazu schauen und
die verpflichtet sind uns über die pässe
zu lassen nicht die dürfen uns die
presse nicht sperren
dann ist das viel besser als wenn wir
schlachten haben in den alpen und jeder
versucht dem anderen die perfektion und
dann führen sie ein etwas was man lernt
bei ihm lernt ja sehr viel dass im
grunde genommen goethe die erste idee
gehabt dazu wilhelm tell
die hat er praktisch schiller übergehen
die hohle gasse muss er kommen ja also
mit den pässen aber das war eine ganz
andere geschichte bei goethe
das waren schon die gleiche geschichte
eigentlich außer güte wie schiller
goethe auf zuerst diese aus den
chroniken studiert in denen die diese
heldengeschichten überliefert sind und
schiller hat die dann auch studiert aber
schiller hatte im kopf das modell von
albrecht von haller dieses
abgeschlossene falkenberg ruhig und da
das wird von einem bösen tyrannen
unterdrückt und dann kommt ein
einzelgänger ein gemsjäger der immer nur
in den felsen herum klettern
und der legt dann diesen tyrannen und
befreite schweizer wunderbare balladeske
geschichte und erhöhte der hat auf einer
seiner schweizer reisen
er kam in die idee zu einem ethos will
ein teil und hat er hat ja immer wenn er
geäußert hat er immer gedichten und er
hat dann wochenlang dieses epos
ausformuliert sicher hätte es
wahrscheinlich schreiben können den
größten teil davon und hat sich aber
kellner die schweiz kannte weil er
wusste dass die schweiz eigentlich das
land besser ist nicht das land der
einsamen felsspitze hatte taylor seinen
lastenträger konzipiert für her über die
presse ging also er hat sozusagen die
wirtschaftliche realität und auch die
internationale realität der schweiz
begriffen und hat ihn so konzipiert und
schiller hat das dann nicht so nicht
interessiert da war auch gar nicht
und das wurde dann auch effektvolle
freiheit saisonaler wie schiller hat der
goethe nicht stand
ich kann mich erinnern als ich 1415 war
wiesen großen streiten meine
deutschlehrerin gehabt über william tell
weil ich gesagt das ist ein schlechter
vater
ein guter vater riskiert nicht so das
leben seines sohns dem apfel also ich
war ganz empört das ist das auch für
schüler ein großes problem und er
diskutiert das ja auch weil seine frau
ihn genau diesen vorwurf macht es das
nie tun dürfen und für schüler war das
natürlich die tragische situation den
gereist
er muss um des schicksals aller anderen
willen beim muss
diesen schutz tun und dann kommen sie
nach diesen entwicklung zu einer
politischen einen politischen diskurs wo
sie im grunde genommen eine andere
wichtige coo der schweiz an greift
nämlich sie angelehnt an alexis de
tocqueville über die demokratie sahen
sie plötzlich wir müssen aufpassen die
mehrheit hat ihn nicht immer recht
und sie sagen damit greifen sie an diese
heilige kuh des volksentscheid denn
mehrheit setzt recht sein sie aber sie
hat nicht immer recht ja das ist ja auch
das sind diese heiligen setzte das volk
soll bestimmen denn der wille des volkes
ist gewissermaßen der wille gottes der
hat recht das ist natürlich ein
russisches kriegsschiff der mensch ist
eigentlich ein sich gut ja und so diese
positive und die mehrheit der menschen
muss auch das ist natürlich blödsinn
weil jeder politischen zeit ist ein
zufalls entscheid und in der demokratie
sagt nicht das volk was recht ist
sondern aus dem volk wird von fall zu
fall eine mehrheit gebildet und die
bestimmt dann was jetzt gilt von jetzt
an und in der schweizer geschichte gibt
es ungezählte sehr für uns sehr wichtige
dinge die von diesem volk von der
mehrheit drei vier fünf mal über
generationen hin immer wieder abgelehnt
wurden
bis sie dann endlich kam das
frauenstimmrecht hinterlassen die
altersversicherung alle das wurde immer
zuerst abgelehnt abgelehnt abgelehnt
dass das ist ja das faszinierende an der
demokratie dass eben auch diesem spiel
charakter hat mit der mehrheit
und dass man das nicht aktualisieren sie
sagen ja entsprechender von der
souveränität des volkes gegenüber der
souveränität der menschheit was das auch
immer ist wer definiert was soll ich da
sagen ja das ist umsatz oder nehmen sie
von tocqueville das übernimmt ja eher
natur
sie übernehmen das mit sympathie ja das
stimmt schon
er sagt wonach bemisst sich denn das
höchste recht also wenn die mehrheit
wirklich ins in bingen dinge entscheidet
die nach dem tiefsten generellen
bewusstsein der mehrheit gegen die
menschlichkeit verstoßen und gegen die
menschenwürde
dann kann die mehrheit nicht recht haben
und dann muss auch unter umständen die
mehrheit zurücktreten oder er sagt dann
aus einen solchen staat würde ich dann
weg gehen und dann machen sie aus gott
überraschend wieder gottfried keller ein
herold topfit und sie sagen der frühere
gottfried keller natur und vernunft
kommen in der mehrheit zusammen und
begrüßen die freiheit und dann ein
vierteljahrhundert später spricht
gottfried keller davon dass die große
mehrheit von einem einzelnen vergiftet
werden kann
das heißt kann in eine diktatur in einem
gleichen nicht unbedingt eine diktatur
ob es sie kann zu sehr problematischen
das wäre dann noch einen schritt weiter
in die diktatur auf das absichern in
deutschland haben das dann erlebten und
ein hort aber er hat schon im 19
jahrhundert gesehen dass das eben die
mehrheit auch verzerrt werden kann
durch neue faktoren und für ihn er hat
bereits an einer anderen stelle gesagt
es wird eine zeit kommen wo in der
schweiz sehr große vermögen sich bilden
und dann das wird im moment sein wo es
sich zeigt was diese demokratie wert ist
er hat also vorausgesehen das problem
des finanzkapitals und und die steuerung
der propaganda durch große vermögen
durch millionen
vermögen die untergründig eingeschossen
werden und die meinungsbildung verändern
das hat er als eine der großen gefahren
der demokratie erkannt und durch meine
wenn sie an amerika denken man könnte
auch an die schweiz denke aber wenn sie
an amerika denkt was da dieses geld für
eine rolle spielt bei der wahl eines
präsidenten
sie müssen ja geld haben und präsident
ja so wir sind die dass das einer der
großen schwierigkeiten der demokratie
der großen probleme die demokratie
und dann tun sie kommen sie wieder zum
gott zurück
in diesen ganzen entwicklungen und sagen
der der einklang von ursprung und
fortschritt als nationalen traum simpel
ist immer wieder der gotthard und jetzt
sagen sie das ist der gotthard-tunnel
also am anfang davon ja das ist so
ungefähr der schweiz neuen stolz dass
das ist das interessante daran ist dass
der dieses unternehmen des neuen
neuesten gott hatten
das nährt to nutzt er riesig ist und der
wieder ein europäisches projekt ist
eigentlich nur einen sinn macht den
europäischen kontext für die schweiz
brauchen wir denn nicht dass das
wiederum mit diesem gott verbunden ist
der gotthard ist so eine art ich sag mal
ist der sinai der schweiz weil man sich
immer wieder auf ihn beruft und man hat
dann auch diesen gott hat obwohl es sich
der höchst design ist ein übergang man
kann ihm nicht zeichnen nehmen keinen
brotzeit das matterhorn ganganzeige
nicht in gott bange aber der gotthard
gilt als die mitte der schweiz und es
gab dann schon früh diesen mythos das
von gott hat alle großen stürme europas
ausgehen also dann die vorstellung die
schweiz ist in der mitte europas das
herz europas und das herz dieses herzens
ist der gotthard und aus dem strömen
alle wasser des kontinents stimmt
natürlich nicht da hin kommt aus dem
englischen und so weiter also es geht
alles ein saison kommen immer wieder
sagen leute die schweiz ist nicht eine
insel sondern die schweiz ist ein
durchgangsland schafft wo man von wo
irgendwie kommt und irgendwo gehen kann
und dazwischen ist die schweiz ja und es
ist wie in einem blutkreislauf mit dem
ganzen kontinent verbunden
aber dann habe ich ein buch ein punkt da
nicht verstanden das war ein bisschen
davor
sie machen ja für die für die festlegung
was ist die schweiz sagen sie ganz
wichtig ist die landesausstellung von
was hat es auf sich ja sie sind ja
richtig fassen hier verlangte landes auf
das ist ja ja wir wollen für mich war
das kriegsausbruch landesausstellung
euro wie haben sie das natürlich auch
versuche eine steinen hühnerhof zu
werfen weil diese landesausstellung war
während des krieges noch in der
nachkriegszeit eine geradezu sakrale
angelegenheit und als das heiligste der
schweiz in erinnerung da hat sich die
schweiz sozusagen selber gefunden und
selber dargestellt und die schweiz wurde
einigung hat sich positioniert
gegründeten diktaturen und so weiter als
es war eine auch eine gewaltige
ideologische angelegenheit dann kamen
die kam die kritik indirekt wellen der
sechziger jahre dann die 68er recht und
die angesagt
unser stand das wasser helvea faschismus
war selbst die flüchtlingsfrage damit
völlig ausgeschlossen beispiel das aber
auch alles andere wurde dann eben als
faschistoid dargestellt aber wenn man
sie genau studiert diese
landesausstellung dann hatte sie zwei
funktion sagte einerseits diese funktion
die schweiz zu verherrlichen und das
negative auszublenden
das ist
bedenklich das ist der kritikwürdig aber
sie hatte auf der anderen seite dazu
geführt dass die fronten in der schweiz
auch die politischen gegensätze für eine
zeit lang ausgeglichen wurde dass er sie
hat dieses prinzip des zusammenschlusses
das prinzip bundesrat ein präsident aber
aus sieben verschiedenen mich war das
hat sie in einer neuen weise reduziert
interpretiert und hat damit sehr
wesentlich mitgeholfen dass sich die
schweiz durch diesen durch diese nazi
zeit irgendwie durchmogeln konzert sich
ja durchgemogelt sie muster jahre
sie musste ja irgendwo immer schauen wie
wie kommen wir durch ich kann da denen
keinen vorwurf mache ich habe damals
schon gelebt bin 37 geboren das dorf in
dem ich aufgewachsen bin sagt neben
einem militärflugplatz also wenn der
krieg los gegangen wäre dann wäre ich am
zweiten tag gewesen
also muss ich denen die die schweiz
durch herausnahme haus gehabt habe vor
den habe ich respekt ich weiß was
passiert ist ich weiß auch was die
flüchtlingspolitik und die grenzen die
zugenommen und es ist aber auch nicht so
dass einfach sämtlicher flüchtlinge
nein aber es gab auch sehr mutige leute
die flüchtlinge trotz im grunde genommen
des befehls keine reinzulassen
reingelassen haben
es ist es ist dieses graue gemisch mia
und alle gesellschaften in einem politik
ist ist natürlich immer ein
durchwursteln sicher dass das wursten
ist am meisten verachtet aber das
durchwursteln ist das was uns immer
wieder rettet weil ja die franzosen auch
nicht alle widerstandskämpfer gewesen
doch was können sie nicht sagen können
ja nicht mehr nach frankreich gut dann
machen sie also man letzten sprung
sie machen aus denen ich sage mal der
literarischen moderne max frisch
dürrenmatt die die die großen kämpfer
ging die natur schlächterei sie sagen
dieses jahren diesen
diese gedanken über fortschritt und die
fortschritte opfer aufgegriffen früh
erfüllt nicht nicht in dem sinne der
jetzt späteren grünen bewegung aber doch
max frisch hat zum beispiel sehr früh
schon vor 50 jahren gesagt es geht nicht
die art wie die schweiz baut wie die
schweiz überbaut wie die schweiz verbaut
wird das ist unmöglich das muss anders
gemacht werden das war in einer zeit als
die schweiz noch ein wunderbar grünes
land war und er hat das gern
vorausgesagt aber man hat es ist nichts
passiert
die schweiz ist nicht ob sie sich ob sie
zum fenster raus stehen schauen wenn sie
durch die schweiz fahren aber ist sie
heute
der schweizerische mit lass ich
zugepflastert ist weitgehend
zugepflastert das ist eine ganz
furchtbare katastrophe und weil sie so
langsam kommt wird das immer nur
teilweise realisiert aber man hat viel
zu spät angefangen dagegen etwas zu tun
und jetzt gibt es aber es gibt es
wirklich in der bevölkerung aufstände
dagegen aber auf der anderen seite sind
die wirtschaftlichen interessen
sie sprechen immer die diskreten
finanzier sie haben so vereine begriffe
und führen land so langsam ein ja die
die machtübernahme des des
finanzkapitals über die schweiz ja ja
das spielt eine rolle und wenn sie
denken jetzt eine wieder zu den alpen
zurückkehren von denen sie die anfang
gesprochen das ist heute eine neue
ausbeutung zone um da gibt es den
widerstand der bevölkerung dagegen aber
es gibt einen gewaltigen druck auf die
ausdehnung dieser ausbeutung der alpen
zu einem riesigen zwei tage mit mit
helikopter landeplätzen und mit zusammen
gehängten mit vernetzten
die systemen und so weiter so dass zu
retten
irgendwo die letzte gämse noch krepiert
und sie sagen mit dürrenmatt und frisch
wie ist aber die fortschritts kritik ist
auch als ätzende ironie der kunden eine
ganze ironie darin weg während früher
das kam gewichtiger daher ja gut also
dass sind diese zwei schriftsteller die
haben ja noch ganz andere probleme
das war für beide war die ökologie
eigentlich nicht noch nie aus meinem 20
hatten frisch hatte sehr intensive
beziehungsproblem knatsch zum probleme
und hat die auch in einer hinreißend
komödiantische weise verwirklicht und
tutow thema von den letzten fragen der
menschheit her gegangen oder das sehr
gut aber das ist so eine frau also ohne
angst im grunde genommen das die
entwicklung der fortschritt uns ihnen
bestimmte katastrophen hört ja und die
haben schon diese beiden großen autoren
anbrechen autoren haben dann eben auch
raum geschaffen für die nachfolgende
generation da kam dann eine durchaus
ökologische generation auch von autoren
die dann noch viel gezielter ökologisch
gedacht und argumentiert hat und dann
prägen sie im grunde genommen dann ein
bild der intellektuellen oder der
schriftsteller aus der schweiz das sind
eigentlich nicht die sind nicht erst
beerdigt nur sondern sind wanderer
zwischen den welten sozusagen sie kommen
sie gehen und kommen so wie in der pd
mobile und das macht ihre stärke
fähigkeit auch nach aus von außen auf
die schweiz zu gucken weil er von der
schweiz auf außen zu haben
das ist sicher es ist ja ganz
interessant dass die wahrscheinlich
schöpferische situation handlungs
situation in der schweizer literatur ist
immer der mann der ins ausland ging und
zurückkehrt und der moment an der grenze
wo er die grenze überschreitet oder
zurückkommt
wo er konfrontierte aus dem bewusstsein
der welt konfrontiert ist mit realität
des landes und diese spannung situation
die hat zu den besten romanen und
theaterstücken der schweiz geführt und
das ist der beweis dafür dass die
schweizer literatur eigentlich eine
literatur der ausschweifenden und
zurückkehrenden es obwohl sie vermerken
dass die flüchtlinge selten im grunde
genommen
thema der schweizer literatur sind es
taucht auf es kommt immer mehr maße in
dem es vielleicht am platz wäre ob auf
der anderen seite muss man sagen die
schweiz auch die schweizer politik die
die entwicklung der schweizer republik
der reim solchen republik ist wesentlich
auch durch leute aus deutschland
vorangetrieben und die kamen hierher und
wurden sofort aktiv und aktivistisch und
haben mitgemacht haben
publizistisch jogger zum beispiel freund
von kleist publizistisch gewirkt
politisch gewirkt die schweiz hat immer
leute aufgenommen und hat sie dann auch
zum teil aus zypern wieder fortgeschickt
aber zum teil hat sie dann wirken lassen
aber die der stoffwechsel zwischen der
schweiz und europa der ist so intensiv
und der so konstitutiv für dieses land
dass man das einfach zur kenntnis nehmen
muss und nicht durch andere heilige
setzte sie einfach klarstellen dass die
auseinandersetzung dies im moment gibt
ja über das bankgeheimnis und so weiter
zwischen europa- oder einzige europa
starten und und der schweiz
glauben sie dass das grundsätzlich das
verhältnis des schweiz mit europa
verändern wird sieht man dinge ein oder
wird man isola isolationistische es
kommt ja nicht auf wann was die
schweizer denken
wenn es das verhältnis der schweiz zu
europa betrifft das sind historische
prozesse das ist ein riesiger
geschichtlicher prozess da können sie
dazu das denken und jenes denken die
geschicht was die geschichte produziert
produziert sie ohnehin und diese ganze
hysterische debatte über das
bankgeheimnis und die schwarzgelder und
all das
das ist ja auch eine europäische prozess
sehen sie wenn die zeitung lesen es wird
in allen ländern genau reicht
diskutieren das ist eine mutation des
internationalen bankensystems was die
schweizer banken gemacht und schweizer
banken sind ja nicht die schweiz die
schweiz wichtig völlig als die schweizer
definieren sich nicht von den banken
herscheider von den gämsen aber wir
heute nicht vorne kann sie sagen ich bin
schweizer
wir haben die ubs das sagt keine da wird
es sich sofort verkriechen wenn ihr
einziger satz trotzdem banken oder die
banker geschaffen zusagen zum schweizer
nationalen stil gehört festgemauert das
bankgeheimnis
das ist ein historischer prozessor den
dreißiger jahren eingeführt hat es auch
gründe dafür gegeben die gar nicht so
negativ waren es ging um den schutz von
von vermögen und dann kalt da so auch
als ein liberales prinzip der staat auch
nicht jederzeit einfach seine nase in
jedes sparbücher einstecken können dann
haben aber natürlich die banken oder
einzelne banken gemerkt was man damit
mit diesem bankgeheimnis auch machen
kann und mit der zeit hat dann jeder
zweite halunke von diktator hat
millionen hier deponiert und das ist
dann das multicar tor von
drogenschmuggler von also viele haben
davon profitiert und da haben natürlich
dann auch
unterstützer unterschiedliche
generationen von wein kann und das hat
dann zu dieser explosion geführt aber
die man muss schon wissen
die schweizer banken sind schon
unmittelbar nach dem krieg ins blickfeld
schafe kritischer blick fällt zb der
amerikaner gekommen
berlin und wer in den goldhandel mit dem
nationalsozialismus
sie musste sich dort mit vielen
millionen freikaufen und hat dann ist
dann aber weil sie der kalte krieg
ausbrach ist sie gewissermaßen geschont
worden
es gab eine schonfrist bis 98 waren die
zwei blog carta kalte krieg vorbei
da kam das mit den nachrichtenlosen
vermögen und die bank nahmen das nicht
vorausgesehen der bundesrat hat das
gerät ist zudem bank gegeben hat gesagt
passt auf da kommt etwas aufzug die
angesagte ist alles dummes zeug
sie ändern ihr buch mit mit einer
witzigen geschichte sie sahen aber das
gewichtigste was sehr gut über die
schweiz wenn jemand über die schweiz
schreiben muss gar nicht immer in der
schweiz gelebt haben um sie geben das
beispiel vom von einem erzähler dessen
name ich jetzt beat sterchi störche sehr
schwer im kanal nach kanada ausgewandert
und in kanada im grunde um ein buch über
emmental bern in einer roten kugel
schrieben hat ja und sie sagen seht ihr
mann kann die schweiz im kopf haben ohne
eigentlich in der schweiz zu sein und
das ist auch wieder einer dieser
auswanderer der die schweiz erst
begreift wenn sie von außen sieht
deshalb sage ich auch irgendwo die
schriftsteller sei genug seien eilig die
als söldner und kreisläufer das sehr
reisen herum sie kommen zurück und sie
haben ein anderes bewusstsein
sie haben einen anderen blick und sie
können auch so erst über die schweiz
freund es gibt es nicht nur in der
schweiz
in stores hat seinen juli zehs zu einem
großen teil in zürich geschrieben also
das spielt dann das irland zürich wieder
welche bedeutung haben heute also heute
meine ich 2013
welche bedeutung haben schriftsteller
intellektuellen oder welchen einfluss
für der schweizerische nachdenken heute
haben sie ein oder ist es eine
vergessene zeit eine überwunden sei nein
man muss diese frage taucht immer wieder
auf man sagt da gab es ja frisch und
dürrenmatt und so weiter aber es ist ja
so dass die zeit des kalten krieges
hatten die intellektuellen eine andere
funktion als sie es heute haben wir
hatten ein andere medien öffentlichkeit
eine viel viel versteinerten
verhältnisse
da hatten die intellektuellen auch die
schriftsteller die in die aufgabe diese
fronten wenigstens aufzubrechen oder
alternative positionen zu signalisieren
oder zu verteidigen sie haben ja wenn
sie in frankreich nehmen zum beispiel
sie haben eher wieder verteidigen sie
den westen remo machen oder sie sind mit
dem kommunismus er in der klang sagt er
zwischen dem kamin dass ich nicht
entscheiden will er wirkt dabei das ist
ja aber an zeit ist vorbei zeit ist
vorbei und wir haben heute eine viel
breitere medienöffentlichkeit wir haben
eine viel heftigeren debatten in den
medien also das was die was frischen
stürmer damals machen mussten das muss
nicht mehr so gemacht werden
aber was wichtig ist ist das
vorhandensein einer kreativen
intelligenz sei das in der literatur sei
dass in anderen sparten wir haben in der
schweiz heute zum beispiel in der
architektur haben wir ganze reihe von
welt architekten das sind auch
intellektuelle man kann nicht machen
ohne über die stadt und das land
fotografen alles mögliche
das ist ein zusammenwirken und es ist
ein fehler wenn man immer sagt wo ist
denn der große wo ist der
nobelpreisträger richtig aber ist die
ökologische zerstörung ist es nicht nur
neue herausforderung für intellektuellen
das ist nicht in den traditionellen
politischen kategorien zu sehen das mag
vielleicht in der schweiz zwischen
ursprung und moderne
vielleicht kann man da zurückgreifen auf
die ganze auseinandersetzung es gibt
diese reflexion natürlich hinter ried in
der gegenwartsliteratur es gibt es gibt
viele schriftstellerinnen und
schriftsteller die sich diesen fragen
stellen und die das eben auch mit den
mitteln der literatur literatur ist ja
nicht einfach racks oder das lied kann
es gelegentlich geben aber das ist
eigentlich selten in der literatur heißt
gute bücher schreiben und sozusagen die
atmosphäre verändert ein schriftsteller
der die atmosphäre an des landes
verändern wenn wir natürlich viel mehr
einen den ausgang einen sein sondern
prozesses erfolgt ich muss ihnen sagen
ich war von diesem 94 seiten total
fasziniert ich habe selten so viel
gelernt und ich möchte mich bei ihnen
bedanken dass ich soviel gelernt hat und
ich hoffe dass unsere zuschauer auch
heute das dass wir das miteinander so
dargestellt dann das ist nachvollziehbar
vielen dank marien und wir sehen uns
irgendwann noch mal wir haben uns vor
einigen jahren im literaturclub gesehen
wir werden uns noch einmal sehen
tschüss und finde das ist ein wort
weitere informationen zu dieser sendung
finden sie auf unserer website
sie finden das gespräch dort auch zum
anklicken und noch mal schauen
oder aber wir stellen die dvd bei uns
bei schweizer radio und fernsehen
redaktions sternstunden 80 52 zürich
ihre e mail schreiben sie an stern
kopien srf punkt ch nächsten sonntag
dreht sich bei srf kultur fast alles um
drei buchstaben drei buchstaben die so
verhängnisvoll wie beglückend sein
können
h die ehe steht im mittelpunkt eines
ganzen radio tages auf sf2 kultur und
sie bietet auch uns hier in den
sternstunden stoff für eine brisante
diskussion nämlich zur frage ob wir
menschen überhaupt dafür taugen zur eine
nicht ganz unkomplizierte hatte auch
richard wagner sowie so war das mit den
frauen so eine sache bei ihnen
vorläufiger schlusspunkt hinter richard
wagner eine innovative film
dokumentation mit dem titel wagner war